y una vigilia a la entrada del capitolio
en recuerdo a los fallecidos el 6 de
enero de 2021 unámonos todos en un
momento de silencio en memoria de los
que perdieron la vida y se sacrificaron
tanto por nuestra democracia aquel día y
silencio en la cámara en donde un año
antes una turba de seguidores de donald
trump intentó tomarse el legislativo
actos conmemorativos que llegaron tras
un duro discurso de joe by de encontrar
el expresidente trump lo acusó de crear
una red de mentiras sobre su derrota en
las elecciones de 2020
values voters vol lo ha hecho porque
valora el poder por encima de los
principios porque considera que su
propio interés es más importante que el
interés de su país y porque su magullado
ego le importa más que nuestra
democracia o nuestra constitución
los actos estuvieron marcados por la
ausencia de los senadores republicanos
incluidos aquellos que hace un año se
desmarcaron de donald trump el ex
presidente por su parte volvió a
insistir en las acusaciones infundadas
de fraude electoral y acusó a bailén de
querer dividir al país
uso mi nombre hoy para tratar de dividir
aún más a eeuu este teatro político es
solo una distracción por el hecho de que
biden ha fallado totalmente solo mire
los números hablan por sí solos no son
justificables por lo que los medios
cómplices simplemente lo llaman gran
mentira cuando en realidad la gran
mentira fue la elección misma entre la
población el temor por el futuro de la
democracia es latente hay fake ver
creo que el derecho al voto y la
garantía del derecho al voto para todos
en eeuu en la cuestión más importante
que tenemos a corto plazo y si no se
toman medidas al respecto me preocupa
mucho el futuro de nuestra democracia
según una encuesta de reuters/ipsos un
año después 55% de los republicanos
siguen creyendo las falsas denuncias de
fraude electoral de donald trump y según
otra de axxion momentive
57% de los estadounidenses creen que
eventos como los del 6 de enero de 2021
se repetirán en los próximos años